auf und bediene präsentiert von der
leyen für oliver längert oder weniger
lang weg sind cool kästner und mike
wittner aus thun suchen das einfache
leben mit ihren kindern wandern sie aus
nach costa rica beatrice und marcel
buholzer aus dem kanton solothurn wurden
noch einmal durchstarten
auf kreta eröffnen sie eine bar von
glarus nach australien familie landolt
möchte mit den ureinwohnern
zusammenarbeiten und betreibt ein ferien
resort in down under
[Musik]
zum letzten mal die immer gleiche
strecke durch das mittelland marcel
buchholz verwandelt aus schon in wenigen
tagen ist er mit seiner frau in
griechenland der solothurner hat
beschlossen dass er mit 57 keine zeit
mehr hat seine träume aufzuschieben
seit 15 jahren arbeitet marcel hier in
niederlenz er verkauft filtertechnik im
außendienst viele stunden hat er täglich
im auto verbracht ist von termin zu
termin gehetzt damit ist nun schluss
noch einmal ist er bei den kollegen in
der firmenzentrale
es ist ein unspektakulärer abschied ohne
großes fest
und genau das machen möchte auf kreta
eine rock und blues bar eröffnen
die pläne dafür hatte bereits genau im
kopf und auch schon eine visitenkarte
und www hoffen
fehlt nur noch die bahn
die rockbar ich für mich sagen der
jugendraum aber sicher besonders lang im
sinn hat und jetzt lebe ich den traum
und träume nicht dein leben
letzte amtshandlung alte
geschäftsunterlagen entsorgen
wie wird marcel als wird nicht mehr
brauchen
ein großer teil von ihm lag sie und
natürlich aber befreien wir dann sehen
geschäfte erledigt
das war's
[Musik]
am fuße des wirklich sind groß ist
familie landolt zu hause
tochter jelena verlässt mit ihren eltern
und den drei geschwistern ihre heimat
und zieht nach australien
mirja die älteste tochter verpackt das
frühstücksgeschirr die männer des
umzugsunternehmens verladen das
persönliche hab und gut der familie in
einen container und verschiffen es nach
mehr als zehn jahre lang hat schülern
gold mit seiner familie hier gelebt nun
muss er sich von lieb gewonnenen trennen
hälfte blieb zurück die andere hälfte
kommt mit jetzt so was ist dort das mit
druck lauth und die womit grund die gott
sie mit dank der islam mit video kann
man nicht auf rinder mit mir oder dann
gekauft hat daraufhin das hat man mit
die poker
als mieter risiko miriam landolt ist die
treibende kraft hinter der auswanderung
als junge erwachsene hat sie ein jahr in
australien verbracht und sich in land
und leute verliebt seitdem träumt sie
davon zurückzukehren
[Musik]
jetzt sind die kinder alt genug und
miriam setzt ihre idee um
besonders da habe ich das wirklich das
land sowohl würden ihren job als
schulleiterin gibt miriam auf in
australien möchte die familie ein ferien
resort kaufen
zusammen mit den ureinwohnern wollen sie
einen besonderen ort für touristen
aufbauen
das ist miriams vision
von sich aus wäre schön nicht auf die
idee gekommen weg zu gehen
der 48 jährige ist in glarus verwurzelt
und hat einen gut bezahlten job als
finanzchef bei einem internationalen
unternehmen den er vorläufig noch behält
seine frau miriam hat ihn für das
projekt mit den ureinwohnern gewonnen es
war nicht sicher wohin genau zu lernen
wie sie trat gesehen und wie sieht das
wie bisher funktioniert ist wie wichtig
war funktioniert nach manderscheid einer
maschine punkt mit ich denke gern an das
höchste was mir daran gehabt als wirkung
das ist die erste ausblick sie dem hus
das ist gläubig sind die grille sie dann
muss ich das tun
[Musik]
der verlobungsring ist heute zum letzten
mal in glarus im einsatz
[Musik]
ja das wusste so ballast abwerfen und
einfach leben das möchte marc widmer mit
seiner familie von thun im berner
oberland geht es nach costa rica in ihr
neues leben neben nicole gerstner und
mike wittner kaum etwas mit selbst die
lieblings möbel lassen sie zurück ins
fernsehen kommt bei freunden unter
nicole und mike haben das auswandern gut
vorbereitet trotzdem bleibt eine
ungewissheit ob noch geld das aus gut du
musst dir sage ja sehr logisch klingt ja
die blogger und haye hat weniger wenige
zum operieren sich auch nachher grund
warum das ist auch meine king hier 13
singles wie kamen sie aus und mit säge
skater mit weniger so wie jetzt gerade
hoch usa statt
darum sei es teil des ganzen
die familie hat ihn tun schon viel
erreicht nico leiter der vier jahre eine
eigene bäckerei danach managte sie
haushalt und kinder
[Musik]
mike gehört ein skate und snowboard
geschäft und er organisiert wintersport
events
ein gutes lied in mir nur gesagt
das paar hat die ersten gemeinsamen
ferien in costa rica verbracht seitdem
sind sie vom lateinamerikanischen
lebensgefühl begeistert nun wagen sie
den schritt in ihr abenteuer werden noch
bis mitte november davor dass sich dann
aber weg und einen schlag weniger mord
besorgen ist was vorher geprobt
[Musik]
den traum vom auswandern gemeinsam leben
das möchte marcel mit seiner frau wegen
das brachte ihnen bringen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in ettenkofen im kanton solothurn ist
marcel zu hause im eigenen haus lebt er
zusammen mit seiner frau beatrice
[Musik]
die 59 jährige hat bis vor kurzem als
verkäuferin in einem schuhladen
gearbeitet
sie ist oft spät nach hause gekommen und
hat marcel kaum gesehen freute sich die
bürger zwar abgeben habe ja vorher eben
sehr viel geschafft und das training
waren sehen dass wir jetzt verlangen
dass ich das gerne
[Musik]
in glarus sind die koffer gepackt alle
bis auf einen fünf liegt allein mit den
kindern nach australien in der firma hat
er dafür ferien genommen
miriam bleibt noch in der schweiz
die 43-jährige schulleiterin ist noch
sechs wochen an ihrem vertrag gebunden
zum ersten mal ist sie für mehrere
wochen von ihren kindern getrennt
das sind ja alles weiß zwischen
reisemittler jänner hat jetzt wo es
losgeht noch jede menge sachen gefunden
die sie auf gar keinen fall zurück
lassen möchte
er hat sich für diesen film
[Musik]
in thun nimmt sich nicole viel zeit für
den abschied
der kindergarten hat für tochter jaz
elle in eine feier organisieren es ist
schon williams letzter tag zu platzieren
kind gar der gute freunde gut die
lehrerin die art wie und was ist das
schwierigste war dahin
[Musik]
nicoles größte sorge
rossellini könnte in costa rica keine
freunde finden
[Musik]
mit sturmhaube in costa rica wird die
sechsjährige eingeschult in die erste
klasse einer internationalen schule die
kinder dort sprechen nur spanisch oder
englisch
ob nicole ihrer tochter zu viel zumutet
[Musik]
in ethik ofen geht es ans eingemachte
aber die rechte wange transportiere das
letzte das ich nicht so einfach es gibt
zwar noch wir sind nervös ich sehe und
wir müssten es geht alles für mit ganz
ganz wenig mit und jetzt sehr viel
richtig wohl noch mal sachen vor in
denen es die musik
das muss mit eine gute musik paarung für
die musik schon als 17-jähriger hat
marcel als roadie für rockbands in
england gearbeitet später stand er am
mischpult
die musik ist marcels leben wir uns
gedacht tricks hat zwei kinder aus
erster ehe
sie war schon einmal verheiratet das
zweite stück und natürlich das ganz klar
sei aber dass durch die pastose wer die
nummer zwei also das kommt klar dass du
heute zu erkunden
na ja ich glaub mir kliniken hatte man
das nicht ausgemacht ob in die frau aus
tätigen selbstständig sie und ihre
eltern aber hey und ich finde es schön
dass medizin ist das vor allem auch hier
kann weitermachen
los ging's hoch ist
[Musik]
es tut mir leid das endspiel
flughafen zürich vater schul und die
kinder schleppen so viel wie möglich aus
der alten heimat mit nach australien
sie müssen auch solle wieder die große
problem damals schon gedanken oder
richtig
die ungewissheit die vor ihm liegt macht
schön zu schaffen
auch großmutter und tante hätten die
kinder lieber in der schweiz
was worden
[Musik]
miriam wird ihre kinder sechs wochen
nicht sehen bevor auch sie nach
australien geht
da video
[Musik]
außerdem brauchen auch ein
der flug dauert 28 stunden mit zwei
zwischenstopps eine reise ans andere
ende der recht
[Musik]
merian muss sich noch gedulden obwohl in
australien ihr herzensprojekt auf sie
wartet
[Musik]
mike ist heute zum letzten mal in seinem
laden in der thuner innenstadt
vor zehn jahren hat er ihn aus dem
nichts aufgebaut und aber von der schufa
pk zur anständigen muss man geht da bist
du es aber hätte führerschaft strom
sogar geforscht
muss ich jetzt durch doch ob das reicht
der 38 jährige ist gelernter zimmermann
und passionierter snowboarder der ersten
stunde
auf zu neuen ufern
den laden behält mike er hat michael
seinen langjährigen mitarbeiter als
teilhaber mit ins geschäft genommen
auch nicole hat ein sicheres polster in
der schweiz
sie hat ein wohn und geschäftshaus von
ihren eltern geerbt und vermietet es in
santa teresa einem mekka für
wellenreiter wurden sie land kaufen und
später ferienhäuser bauen
schon bald werden sie jacken und mützen
gegen shorts und flipflops tauschen aber
vorher machen ihnen freunde aus thun das
auswandern noch einmal ordentlich schwer
in einer bar haben sie eine abschieds
party organisiert
[Musik]
nettekoven schüttet es wie aus kübeln
als der möbelwagen ankommt
es wurde zwischen bogen politischen
marcel und tricks wollten geld sparen
und haben ein unternehmen aus
deutschland beauftragt zudem teilen sich
die auswanderer den lastwagen mit einem
anderen kunden sich schon mal beginnen
und disco-beats gutes problem das die
profis die es sicher wir packen können
ja ich gut
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
einige der möbelstücke sind noch
original verpackt tricks hat sie extra
für kreta gekauft
denn sie weiß bereits genau wie sie ihre
wohnung dort einrichten will
[Musik]
in glarus kommt miriam zurück ins leere
haus
[Musik]
totenstill echt mal gespannt ob wir sie
wieder so sein damit ihnen ein auskommen
[Musik]
ja
jetzt ziehen sie die luft
[Musik]
schul und die vier kinder haben es
geschafft nach einem flug um die halbe
welt und mit wenig schlaf kommen sie in
coffs harbour an
freunde erwarten sie
die australier kennen die familie schon
seit vielen jahren im zukünftigen ferien
resort sind sie für die landes wichtige
partner
schon lange haben sie sich auf die
familie gefreut doch für ausruhen bleibt
keine zeit schul und die kinder müssen
sich in der neuen heimat einrichten
[Musik]
bei tricks und marcel sind bisher nur
die möbel unterwegs aber jetzt gilt es
auch für das ehepaar los und für ihre
beiden katzen
[Musik]
laufen sie noch einmal verabschiedet
ich schaue nicht so einfach freunde
bringen sie zum flughafen nach genf in
rund zwei stunden müssen sie einchecken
ihr haus haben sie verkauft
[Musik]
marcel und tricks haben ein
one-way-ticket nach kreta gekauft eine
rückkehr in die schweiz ist nicht
vorgesehen
[Musik]
das neue zuhause von familie landolt
liegt an der regenreichen ostküste nur
wenige autominuten von coffs harbour
entfernt
wo passiert
das gelände ist 40 hektar großen ferien
bungalows stehen darauf und das wohnhaus
der familie
kostenpunkt 2,4 millionen franken
das ist mehr als die planer besitzen und
die finanzierung ist noch nicht geregelt
der finanzfachmann vertraut jedoch
darauf dass er investoren findet die ihr
spezielles projekt unterstützen
gallen jamba ort des quellwassers nennen
die aborigines dieses land als frau will
hier ihre vision vom leben und arbeiten
mit den ureinwohnern verwirklichen
das ganze familie auch für schul- und
die kinder soll australien zur heimat
werden nach altem ritual der aborigines
begrüßt schoss miss die schweizer
willkommen zu hause
ich möchte euch gerne ein wort des
stammes der homberger beibringen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in zürich machen sich die thuner bereit
für den abflug
anderthalb jahre haben sie auf diesen
tag hingearbeitet
doch der letzte schritt zu ihrem großen
traum
fällt ihnen schwerer als gedacht
[Musik]
bis im forum oder
ja
das
für nicole ist das loslassen besonders
schwierig die freunde sind ihre familie
denn ihre eltern sind bereits gestorben
[Musik]
zusammen
nun gibt es kein zurück mehr
mike nicole und die kinder sind auf dem
weg in ein einfacheres leben
[Musik]
san jose costa rica am nächsten morgen
kaum angekommen hat die familie ihren
ersten termin
mike hat noch von der schweiz aus hier
ein auto bestellt und die familie
braucht der pick up für ihr leben am
neuen wohnort ja genau den herrn pakula
aguilar entschuldigung kein problem
der ist gleich bei ihnen nehmen sie doch
einen moment platz er ist in fünf
minuten da alles scheint perfekt
doch nach dem freundlichen empfang fühlt
sich niemand mehr für sie zuständig und
vom neuen pick-up keine spuren in der
nächsten folge von auf und davon erfährt
mike dass er noch länger auf sein auto
warten muss der wagen ist nicht fertig
nun sitzt die familie in der
jugendherberge in san josé fest in
australien erkundet schön mit den
kindern das riesige gelände ihres resort
wo haben sie dich erwischt hier im show
mirja erlebt eine böse überraschung und
muss sie ohne ihre mutter miriam
durchstehen und schwieriger start auf
kreta die wohnung ist ganz anders als
trick sie sich vorgestellt hat
irgendwie ist doch dazu kommen probleme
mit dem linken fuß durch zeigt bei der
ich glaube hier muss nicht ja niveau von
können
träumen
die wiener
[Musik]
sie waren das abenteuer
sie waren dann aus schweizer radio und
fernsehen möchte sie bei ihrem neuanfang
bereiten
die kameras sind mit dabei wenn sie die
altes leben gegen ein neues 1000 melden
sie an auswandern srf punkt ch oder
schreiben sie an schweizer radio und
fernsehen stichwort auswandern 80 52
zürich und tv infos präsentiert wurde
der leyen verlängert oder weniger lang
weg sind